des baraques en préfabriqué à perte de
vue le camp acabit le plus grand camp de
réfugiés syriens au monde est devenu en
dix ans une ville semi permanente où la
survie s'organise tant bien que mal
voici notre logement nous dit oui ben
ali c'est l'imprévu il nous présentera
lille cinq ans
sous l'oeil de six ans qui souffrent du
diabète est le benjamin de la fratrie
mohamed 6 mois les trois fils de web
sont nés dans ce camp et grandir ont
probablement derrière ces murs large
sourire regnauld je suis réfugiée dans
ce camp depuis huit ans j'avais 19 ans
et j'attends depuis quatre ans une
réponse du canada à ma demande donateurs
ou arrive n'a pas pu poursuivre ses
études et son statut ne lui permet pas
de travailler et comme si ce n'était pas
assez il doit prendre en charge sa
famille et ses deux parents
sa mère a subi un accident vasculaire
cérébral il ya quelques jours elle est
désormais hémiplégique et pour la
soigner il faudrait l'assortir du camp
et débourser des frais médicaux et de
physiothérapie privé une fortune pour
lui
attendre ne serait ce qu'un jour dans
ces conditions est insoutenable je veux
offrir une meilleure vie à ma famille à
mon fils diabétiques à ma mère
cette incompréhension est partagé par
aline le frère aîné de wahib tout le
dossier les correct tout est correct une
amende de quelque chose manque que
manquait quelque chose tout est bon mais
on en entend khalil a eu plus de chance
il y a cinq ans l'ambassade du canada en
jordanie lui avait offert de se
réinstaller au pays quand j'ai reçu le
label
jumeaux une petite lumière dans leurs
dents noires la famille s'est établie à
saint constant et c'est même agrandie
avec la naissance des 6e enfant tous
sont citoyens canadiens
on dit merci canada beau juste arrivé
ici c'est beaucoup pour nous quand on en
rêvait on a commencé 00
00 argent 0 langue 0 maison 0 à hamid 0
famille on a comment se construire toute
la vie ils ont appris le français râlent
ils travaillent à temps plein et il a
même acheté une maison à crédit
aujourd'hui il espère partager un peu de
cette prospérité avec le reste de la
famille mon père ma mère elle va
installer ses membres à un moment à
montbrison chez nous mais mon frère
ce sont fermés pour lui mais tout le
peuple
tout ce processus de parrainage a été
pris en charge et initié par un groupe
de citoyens canadiens des résidents de
amine freund il ya cinq mois ils ont
enfin reçu une bonne nouvelle un message
du ministère de l'immigration du québec
leur annonçant l'arrivée possible de la
famille al ahly et leur demandant de
soumettre un plan de quarantaine depuis
ils n'ont plus de nouvelles mon choix
comme réponse si vous ne dérangez tout
ça risque de prendre encore plus de
temps sur ses jeans carrément je n'ai
cessé d enfants ça peut pas être plus
menaçant que ça me semble que c'est la
moindre des choses c'est assez donné la
même heure même chance à tous les
enfants les membres de la communauté
partout
puis dans les entends nous demande quand
est-ce qu'ils vont arriver comment va
votre projet ça fait longtemps est ce
que c'est à cause de trouver le
ministère de l'immigration nous assure
que le canada a une longue et fière
tradition d'offrir une protection à ceux
qui en ont le plus besoin en offrant un
refuge aux personnes les plus
vulnérables du monde au 31 mars 2022
seize mille trois cent soixante cinq
dossiers de réfugiés syriens sont en
cours de traitement
les délais de traitement varie de 28 à
35 mois le parrainage de la famille al
ahly a commencé en 2018 ce processus est
assez long et il est difficile d'obtenir
un suivi nous rappelle cette avocate on
devrait la place de plus de compassion
des domaines de plus d'efforts et de
moyens pour faire venir ces personnes là
parce qu'on sait très bien une fois
qu'ils sont installés vont contribuer
vont devenir canadien et et la vie
continue mais tout délai tout délai pour
les enfants s'établir au canada va avoir
des impacts dans leur vie future
khalil et son épouse s'accrochent à
leurs téléphones et aux rares photos de
leur famille dans le camp pour les
épauler dans cette succession d'épreuves
les membres du groupe de parrainage se
relie à leurs côtés
l'histoire de la famille dhalla mais
cette histoire est représentative de
quelque chose de beaucoup plus grand
nettement plus important il faut il faut
vraiment qu'on qu'on règle qu'on répare
le système l'arrivée de la famille al
ahly au canada ne serait qu'une question
de temps mais c'est justement ce qui
manque cruellement